good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining the ottawa police
for this update to the community
on the ongoing
demonstration this update will be
followed by media availability
mercedes knows
here my name is constable amigano and i
will be your moderator
we will begin
with remarks from ottawa police deputy
chief steve bell
steve bell
thank you very much amy good afternoon
everyone the ottawa police service and
its partners continue to work all out to
put a safe end to the unlawful
occupation of our downtown core and
improve neighborhood safety
our surgical contain strategy which has
reduced the footprint of the
demonstrators continues as we do police
operations our police operations are
focused on enforcement in our downtown
core
yesterday an important court order was
issued in relation to the demonstration
the ottawa police service is authorized
to enforce compliance with the terms of
a court order the auto police service
continues to have authority under
section 127 of the criminal code to
arrest and lay a charge for breaching a
court order
auto police officers will exercise their
discretion in enforcing this order and
any criminal investigation arriving from
arising from an alleged breach of this
world
we're working to ensure we're enforcing
your work is underway to fully brief all
officers on the terms of the order and
their role in enforcing it we continue
to capture and document evidence we'll
have an update on this later today
as more resources become available to us
we will use them specifically to focus
on the unlawful demonstrators whom have
chosen to remain in our city to date
we've made 22 arrests issued more than 1
300 tickets and have 79 ongoing criminal
investigations we've seized fuel and cut
off material financial and logistical
support to the occupation
i also want to be clear we're not just
dealing with demonstrators in auto
yesterday working with ohio police we
were able to trace identify and arrest
an individual for calling in fake
threats designed to deceive and distract
our emergency resources
many of the remaining demonstrators are
highly determined and volatile they've
begun filling gas canisters with water
distracting officers or otherwise
attempting to subvert our efforts
yesterday we had an attack on our
hard-working officers while attempting
to seize fuel from demonstrators
multiple officers were swarmed by these
same demonstrators we've initiated a
criminal investigation into this matter
we've seized and towed some vehicles and
continued to face resourcing and
operational challenges and doing more
many heavy vehicles in the downtown core
have been immobilized
recent aggressiveness towards our
officers is unacceptable we've
identified our need for the 1800
officers and civilian personnel that
will bring a safe end to this occupation
we do not want anyone to be injured
we know that some demonstrators have
indicated a desire to leave in some
cases they're blocked in by other
vehicles and where possible we're
working to facilitate their departure
through intelligence we've also learned
that almost 25
of the 418 trucks encamped in our city
have children living in
children who could be at risk during a
police operation we're working with the
children's aid society to ensure their
welfare and safety
finally our message to demonstrators
remains the same don't come and if you
do there'll be consequences including
financial consequences for your illegal
and unlawful behavior thank you
before we begin
a reminder to media to put your
microphone on mute until i invite you to
ask your question
please
also we do have
emergency services general manager kim
ayotte from the city who's a subject
matter expert
and he will be off camera unless
questions are asked directly to him
we will proceed by alphabetical order
for the media outlets
you may ask one question each
and if we have time we will come back to
you we have until 2 30.
so we will start do we have anyone from
psychiatrists
i do not see anyone from set we will
move on to cbc ottawa
cbc ottawa
just a minute
step
my question mr bell you told about you
told us about an attack and mr slowly
talked about injuries to some of your
officers as well can you
give us an idea of how many officers
were injured and the kind of injuries
that they suffered
um i um
in terms of is serious injuries to our
officers um we're very fortunate to
report that we we haven't had any to
this point
um there has been during altercation
some more
minor injuries sustained by the officers
but nothing that has taken any of our
members
out of commission or not able to
continue to provide policing services
merci thank you and now we'll go with
cbc ottawa i see that kate porter is
here
so kate will be
giving you the mic shortly and you can
ask one question
hi
thank you uh deputy chief bell when you
speak of um i guess it's something like
a hundred trucks that have children in
them and you're saying the cas is
involved um are you requiring that they
somehow are able to remove the children
from the trucks i mean what would be the
next steps for police
in terms of um
you know moving on any of those trucks
if if you're concerned about kids
uh yeah thank you very much for your
question kate so uh we we identify that
concern for us it's something that has
come to us uh early in in the course of
this occupation we we observed through
members uh who are
moving around within the crowds that
they they began to saw uh children
families that were actually had attended
here to take part in the occupation uh
it's something that greatly concerns us
it's something that concerns us for the
well-being of everyone within the area
from the risk of
carbon monoxide and fumes the noise
levels that we know are experienced by
the neighborhood the neighboring
areas as well as the people that are
right in the occupation occupation uh
we're concerned about cold we're
concerned about access to sanitation um
uh
the ability to
shower um there's a multitude of
concerns that's why we're raising it and
identifying it as something that is a
that is something we need to address we
need to have discussions with our
partners in the children's aid society
about how uh we manage moving ahead
we're not at the stage of looking um to
do any sort of
enforcement activity around that we'll
rely on the children's aid society to
help provide and give us guidance around
that we just think it's an important
factor that's in that that complicates
and and and makes this an even more
challenging operation that that's
important that people are aware of
thank you kate we'll now go to
city news and we have alex gouge alex
you can go ahead and ask your question
hello so my question is for deputy chief
steve bell and
how logistically does it how much
difficulty does the fact that people are
bringing in water in these fuel tanks
how hard is how much difficulty does
that put on the ottawa police service in
terms of enforcement
uh thanks for the question alex um it
it's a it's a good one um what i can
tell you is
it does provide a layer of logistical
complexity to us if the number of of gas
cans going in uh it creates challenges
for us
to actually conduct searches to stop and
conduct searches ultimately
sees those those gas cans and and the
fuel in them and potentially charge
someone as a result of that
the other thing it it does for us is it
is identifies a level of sophistication
and a level of ability of this group to
try and subvert police efforts that's
concerning to us um we know where we
continue to have discussions with the
demonstrators about the occupation we we
are actively looking to find remedies
and resolutions to end this
um but we know that as as they harden in
their position and as they try and
engage in activity that subvert our
efforts it's quite concerning to us
thank you alex next we'll go to ted
raymond
with ctv ottawa
ted you can go ahead thank you uh my
question is also for deputy chief bell
i'm asking about uh you mentioned off
the top that uh several of the vehicles
uh that are uh parked downtown have been
immobilized uh we've heard of uh reports
of vehicles having their tires or their
wheels taken off that sort of thing um
how does that affect
your abilities to
to
start to remove these vehicles i know
the city's also had trouble getting uh
towing
companies to to cooperate um
in terms of
actually moving the vehicles that are
blocking streets out of the downtown you
know what is what are your next steps
and
when
can we see more of that action taking
place
given the situation
uh thanks for the question ted yeah um
the the immobilizing of the vehicles in
in the occupation area is is extremely
concerning to us you're you're
absolutely right we've seen vehicles
that have had their their tires taken
off uh we've seen larger vehicles that
we know have had their their brakes bled
to make them rendered immobile
we identified early on there there's
many uh layers of complexity to
dismantling this occupation one of them
is the sheer size of it it covers as we
know many blocks within our city's down
court downtown core the other challenge
is the size of the vehicles when you add
the complexity of of active attempts to
to
interfere with any of our ability to
remove them it just adds that extra
layer of complexity what i can tell you
is it's something that we're absolutely
considering it's something we're
planning around and ultimately at the at
the end of this uh when when the
occupation is over and and people go
home we know that we're going to have to
do some cleanup in that area and we're
making
we're making operational plans to
actually achieve that
thank you we will now to go to global
news craiglord
right you can go ahead
hi there thank you um so we know we've
heard a lot about the need for
additional officers 1800 more personnel
but looking at all the options available
to the police in the criminal code
powers potentially granted by the courts
or declarations by the province or the
federal government
does the ottawa police service currently
have all the legal authority that you
feel you need to end this protest or are
there additional powers or authorities
you're going to be seeking to acquire
before this can officially be
routed and ended
my apologies thank you for the question
craig um as we indicated uh very early
on in the early days of this all
everything is on the table for us to
consider in terms of options um you are
absolutely right there are
several at legal avenues that we need to
we need to explore and continue to
explore as part of our ask um in
resources to come and assist us
it it is not only uniformed officers to
be engaged in in our front line front
facing activities we have within their
lawyers legal legal competencies that
we're seeking from various different
agencies including transport canada
the ministry of transportation ontario
experts in insurance experts in um in
licensing and registration of these
types of vehicles these types of large
trucks so we do know there are seven
several avenues for us to explore we've
brought together an investigative
strategy that looks at all of those
different avenues and we will use
everything within our means that
currently exists and explore anything
else that we need to have out to our
toolbox to hold the people that are
engaged in this accountable
thank you we'll now go to the ottawa
citizen matt lapierre matt you may go
ahead
good afternoon deputy chief bell i was
just wondering if you can give us any
kind of updated timeline um you know do
you expect the the protest to continue
through this weekend did the police have
any kind of new operating timeline any
expectation
uh thank you very much for the question
matt so from the beginning we
we've never
identified timelines for this we want
this occupation to end as soon as
possible we want these demonstrators to
pick up uh realize that their message
has been heard and go home to where they
came from so that our citizens can have
their city back
we feel we deserve this and our citizens
are are very loud in calling for this to
end uh we continue to work every day to
as expeditiously and safely end the
occupation so our the citizens of ottawa
can have their city back
thank you matt we now go to john willing
with the ottawa sun
john it shouldn't be long and your mic
should be unneeded
thanks amy thanks deputy for taking our
questions um how many in-house heavy tow
trucks does ops and the city have
um and are those resources in play or
have they been ruled out because of uh
any safety concerns in the red zone
uh thanks for the question john um
as with any sort of policing operation
we don't give out specific numbers
around how we're going to engage uh in
any sort of enforcement activities so
what i can tell you is we continue to
work with the city
and local tow truck providers to look at
how we can access the number of heavy
tows that we would need uh in the event
that we have to move vehicles out of the
downtown core and we've expanded that
through our city manager and our our
city partners to look not only at our
city but how can other cities and other
municipalities help to support us in
those efforts
thank you john i met now valerie
frederick pepe
so deputy chief bell i'm not sure if you
if you can answer in in
i heard you say hello so
um so this is what i'm going to do i'm
going to ask you the question deputy
chief and maybe um mr ayat can also give
me
um a comment on that
but i but it's really a police question
so i'm gonna give it to you in english
um so you mentioned a bit people walking
around with jerry cans
and uh some are filled with water some
are not
and we saw there was a big operation on
sunday in on coventry so so what's
what's your strategy and i know you
can't give us all the details but what's
the strategy for for fuel right now are
we going to stop everyone that we see
with jerrycans or do we want to do more
organized more bigger
operations to try to get
more logistical spaces where there's
more fuel that is stored because we're
seeing a lot of jerry cans walking
around so so what's the what can you
tell us about that
yep thank you for uh thank you for your
question frederick um
we don't have a strategy around that we
have multi-prongs to our enforcement
strategy that we're employing we put out
a statement yesterday that indicated
that if you carry a jerry can into the
downtown core into the footprint of the
demonstration you would be subject to
being stopped uh searched and
potentially charged in relation to
aiding and abetting the demonstration
moving ahead while we were doing that
and while we were engaged in those
enforcement activities we were also out
of coventry road looking at how we could
take off the larger stockpile
the larger stockpile of fuel that we
knew existed there is no single strategy
to this
we will do everything in our power to
disrupt uh and deter these people from
remaining in our city so that the
demonstrators pick up and leave that
includes multiple different prongs of
enforcement that we are engaged in now
and will increase over the days
thank you we'll now go to mackenzie gray
with ctv national
so sorry amy i think
wanted uh
he didn't like my hellos so
diesel excuse me
um
[Music]
excuse
so that now covers our local media if we
have time we will come back and we will
now start with our national media
so we're going to go to ctv national
mackenzie gray
go ahead mackenzie
hi there thanks for taking questions
today uh questions for uh deputy chief
bell
yesterday when we were at a press
conference with uh the police chief he
was talking about how there was going to
be strict enforcement of the no fuel
moving into the downtown core
literally at the same time he was
telling me that at the press conference
our crews were out downtown saw
wheelbarrows full of jerry cans going
right by police officers and when we
asked the police officers why they
didn't stop them they said that while
there might be water in there so they're
free to move into the area why should
anyone in the city believe that the city
uh why the police are actually going to
be able to enforce this when we have
concrete examples of large amounts of
fuel and jerry cans moving into the
downtown core and the police standing by
and doing that
uh thank you for your question mackenzie
um and it's it's a really good question
yesterday you you saw us lay out the
request for
augmented resources to come into the
city to help us manage the situation
around the demonstration around the
occupation and the demonstrators that
were in that area
one of the things we identified in early
days is it was going to be really
important for us to to cut off the flow
of fuel into that area
as you've just indicated through um
through the pictures that you've taken
there are many many different different
ways different places that that flow is
coming in through we believe that the
1800 officers and and civilian members
that we've requested will help us harden
up the perimeter of that that will lead
us to be able to have better success in
in interdicting fuel as it enters into
into the demonstration area
we are doing interdiction there is no
doubt there were several charges
yesterday several seizures yesterday of
gasoline we also have the example where
one of our members was swarmed during
one of those interdictions
and ultimately we had to bring a public
order team in to help protect the member
affect the arrest and take uh take the
subject and our members out of that area
it is important that we have the right
number of of officers right number of
members present to be able to safely
affect those arrests and safely do those
interdictions that's why we've asked for
the numbers of officers we had to make
sure that we can do the enforcement job
that we know we need to do
thank you mackenzie i do believe that
michelle allen from the cbc kingston you
had your hand up earlier so michelle
if you have a question
we'll be going to you
hi thank you um
my question is why haven't the police
considered removing the protesters
before removing their vehicles if local
companies won't help seize the vehicle
that impounds them also couldn't you
just go to the military who have lots of
heavy recovery vehicles and the means to
send their personnel and bring them in
uh thank you for your question michelle
um
as we indicated
early on in this
we're looking at all sorts of different
options to
safely peacefully um and expeditiously
end this this occupation have these
demonstrators removed from our street
have them move from our street so that
we can back get back to life as normal
in autumn
we look at all sorts of options for
removing the vehicles uh and having the
people who are in that area
either leave willingly or leave through
intervention by our police services all
of those options still remain on the
table and we will continue to look at
how we manage the situation and what we
need to do at any point to peacefully
end this
okay thank you we're going to go to the
christy kirkup from the globe and mail
followed by
standby also followed by tonda with the
toronto star and then we're going to be
asking
media to raise their hands because we
will have time for some more questions
so christy do you have a question
hi thank you good afternoon
downtown ottawa residents have expressed
they're very concerned about the images
of the alleged uh arsonist starting a
lobby fire at a condo building and then
taping the doors shut and i know that um
the police forces posted uh images of
suspects i'm just wondering if you can
tell us about
what uh police believed happened there i
appreciate you've said that there is an
investigation underway and there's
limitations on on how much you can get
into that but is there any reason to
believe there is a connection with the
trucker protests and have the suspects
been identified
uh yeah thank you for your question
christy um as i reported yesterday there
there was um images that were captured
of that as part of the initial com
complaint that we received uh we have
investigative teams who are assigned to
that those images have been taken
and shared through widely through our
networks across the country
in order to look to identify the people
involved in that very troubling very
terrible act
um
we absolutely understand the um the
community's concern around something as
dangerous as that so we actively are
investing in it i don't have an update
for you on that now but what i can tell
you is i do know that incidents like
that are creating great amounts of
community concern in the neighborhoods
that are surrounding this demonstration
although we don't have any direct
linkage between the occupation the
demonstrators and that act uh the
community is at at a heightened risk
because of those activities we take that
very very seriously and that's why
you've seen our
our increased presence in a surge
capacity and our increased enforcement
in those neighborhoods to try and ensure
that those residents have safety and
security in their own neighborhoods in
the houses that they live i know today
a community meeting is occurring between
the local award counselor and members of
that building and the ottawa police are
actually a part of that that meeting as
well
in
ensuring that people feel safe where
they live is ultimately absolutely
important to the ottawa police service
and we are doing taking all steps to
make sure that that feeling of safety
and security comes back
thank you and now we'll go to tonda
mccharles from the toronto star
go ahead tanda and ask the question
you are on mute sorry about that now i'm
back sir good to go
thanks debbie bell uh i may have missed
it but i didn't unless you already said
how many of those extra 1800 resources
you've been actually
given if you've nailed that down um if
you have already said that i wonder if
you could just clarify but my my
question really goes to we've already
heard the federal government say that
they are not prepared to talk to this
these convoy organizers this afternoon
the public safety minister called them a
small minority very angry it's no longer
about truckers or vaccines so given the
federal government's position on that i
want to know i haven't heard you say
what the plan out of this is then if
they're if if they want to talk to the
feds the feds won't talk to them and
you're only in charge of logistics you
seem to be powerless to change anything
uh thank you very much for your question
thomas so i'll start with the numbers we
put an ask out for 1800
officers officers sworn and civilian
members we continue to work with our
partners and with our planning teams to
identify
exactly where those officers are going
to be coming from we have had some uh
we've from the beginning of this we've
had absolute cooperation with
many of our partners the rcmp and the
opp have provided
resources to us to help support us
police services across ontario have
actually identified resources to come
and help work with us that cooperation
absolutely continues and we thank all of
our policing partners for their help and
assistance through this uh in terms of
of how we move forward we continue to to
look at how we have fruitful dialogue
and discussions with leaders within the
uh within the occupation within the
demonstrators we have uh strong police
liaison team assets who are deployed on
a daily basis and have ongoing and
regular conversations with these uh with
the people who are leading this
occupation um that's super that is
exceptionally important for us that we
continue to have those dialogues as we
move through we will continue to look at
all of the options we have you've seen
an increased enforcement presence from
us to date we've had over 1300 charges
of we've had over 1300 traffic
violations identified you've heard me
lay out
an overall investigative strategy to
look at how we lay criminal charges lay
uh vehicle related charges now and
moving ahead there there is absolutely a
need to end this we are actively working
to do it through peaceful uh progressive
negotiations but we also have looked at
enforcement angles to move us ahead
thank you and before we move on to a
possibility of a few more questions
i want to make sure that every media has
been able to ask so if you have not been
able you could raise your hand and i do
see
laura laura osman
so we'll give you the mic and just
identify what media you're with before
you ask your question it won't be long
hey there laura osmond the canadian
press
um i wanted to ask you again about this
1800 officers that you're looking for
you mentioned earlier that you sort of
need more officers in order to sort of
harden that perimeter so a lot of people
are wondering why the city doesn't file
sort of more injunctions to get the
vehicles out of there
but if they did would you actually be
able to
enforce that with the officers you have
at this point or is is it a resource
issue
thanks for the question laura um so the
1800 officers are are for a
multitude of different activities um
you've heard us talking about
hardening the area around
around the demonstration and around the
occupation
it takes upwards of 400 plus officers a
day to manage that footprint that we
currently have and actively look to
shrink that footprint
beyond that we know that we we need
legal resources we know we need
investigative resources to look at the
investigative strategy that we are
looking to implement to create increased
enforcement activities we know that we
need public order
assets to be here to support us as was
evident yesterday as we began to do
a fuel interdiction as it went into the
uh as it went into the the site of the
occupation
it will it is going to take and we've
identified a number of resources to come
in and support us to end this we are
absolutely committed to to ending this
and that's why we've made the large ask
we had so that we can have the presence
we need to successfully expeditiously
and quickly end this occupation
thank you and i've just been advised
that dc bell was actually going to have
to leave earlier so we have time for
three more questions and i'm um
okay i just see that geek and cbc
so we'll let g ask a question
you are good to go
go ahead gee we your mic should be
unmuted we should be able to hear you
hi this is actually charlie lee from
city news i'm sorry for the i didn't
realize uh
my question i'll just get to my question
concerns the the staging areas being
used by protesters i understand that
police have moved to dismantle the one
at
at confederation park but there's also a
staging area on coventry coventry road
i just want to know does ops know how
many staging areas
convoy protesters are currently using
and what's being done to discourage the
establishment of further staging areas
in suburbs like vanier
that could potentially essentially move
some of the
undesirable elements of these protests
into other neighborhoods
thank you for your question um
right from
right from the beginning of this as as
we started to have discussions and bring
in bring uh planning around we we really
strongly relied on gathering
intelligence and information around
the progress of the convoy across canada
ultimately the initial weekend
demonstration that led to the occupation
we're currently seeing we continue to
work with partners between the opp
uh the rcmp uh the strategic quebec and
the gatineau police to bring
intelligence information in to identify
things exactly like those fuel
depots that we're seeing we will
continue to bring that information in
and as we learn about them and develop
plans around them we will actively shut
them down because we know they are a
major source of contribution to keeping
the activities of the occupation going
thank you and i apologize for the
pronunciation of your name
we will we have time for one final
question and it will be ted raymond with
ctd ottawa go ahead ted i believe you
did have a second question
yes thank you um i wanted to ask uh
deputy chief about the mood among the
rank and file police force now we've got
a city basically questioning
how you're doing your job
i wonder if you could just talk a little
bit about what morale is like
and just as a as an aside to that with
with bringing in these 1800
additional resources would that be a
would that be a boost
thank you very much for asking that
question ted
um
our members are tired i'm they're they
are very tired they go out every single
day down to our downtown core to try and
take back a portion of our city that's
been lost to this occupation they work
extremely hard in cold weather and
extremely difficult conditions
to manage this uh this dem what is a
demonstration and occupation and they
find it extremely challenging um the
morale is um
the morale is challenged through this
there's no other way to put it this is
an extremely difficult job they continue
to work day in and day out some of our
resources had to work seven days
straight up to 18 hours a day in order
to keep the city safe
they've done an exceptional job and i am
extremely proud of the work they're
doing everything they do is here to help
support safety and security in our
community and particularly to support
the safety and security of the residents
who are affected directly by this
occupation
it has been a challenge for them they
continue to show up every single day and
do amazing work
we asked for 1800 officers which is a
big ask because our members need that
help and support in order to bring this
to an end
i'm glad you asked about our officers
because this has been challenging for
them and i got to tell you i'm proud of
the work that they do every single day
thank you and before we close i'm gonna
offer mr ayotte if he has any remarks
that he would
like to provide and then that'll be the
end of today's media availability
thank you for that i just want everyone
to know that the city is doing
absolutely everything possible to help
support the uh police in this and
um we've had staff working very hard as
well and we're all very anxious to get
this completed and over with
so please
you know know that we are working
extremely hard to try and resolve this
issue and we're engaging all levels of
government to try and do so thank you
[Music]
foreign
merci thank you this concludes today's
30-minute question period
thank you very much for joining us
mercedes and josue